on any discussion of ancient Persia we
quickly talk about the faith of the
Achaemenid Empire and that's Xaro astron
ism and it's popularized by Cyrus the
Great when he establishes the Achaemenid
Empire takes over the median Empire the
babel the neo-babylonian empire the
Lydians his son canvases takes over the
Egyptians and their faith is based on
the teaching of Zoroaster and so aster
is the Greek name for Zarathustra and
sometimes the religion is referred to as
Zarathustra anism and it's one of the
oldest religions we have and it's an
existing religion people still practice
Zoroastrianism in terms of when it
started there's some debate a lot of
accounts have it starting as early or
even earlier than 3,500 years ago so
around 1500 BCE and some accounts put it
a little bit closer to Cyrus the Great
maybe 700 or 600 BCE and the accounts or
the beginning of our religion is really
around the teachings of Zarathustra and
his teachings really established one of
the first often viewed as monotheistic
religions of the world this idea that
there is one God and that God in the
Zoroastrian faith is Ahura Mazda who are
a Mazda and it's bully it's viewed that
Ahura Mazda does not take a human form
and is even you cannot even conceive of
a you know fully conceived the human
mind can't fully conceive of a Mazda but
it who a Mazda is the in the Zoroastrian
faith the one and only God but in
conjunction with the idea of a who are
Mazda a lot of people refer to as or
Astron ISM as a dualistic fate a
dualistic faith a dualistic faith means
that there's this kind of interest in in
counterbalancing forces for example
light versus dark and of course good
versus evil and one of the main ideas or
words here are the ideas of Asha and ruj
so asha these are the ideas of being
prince
pulled honest ordered and ruj is the
opposite the Rouge is the idea of being
unprincipled dishonest chaotic and so
there's a lot of talk and and kind of
inside or trying to get a better
understanding of these dualistic natures
in the world and trying for humanity
beyond the sight of the good the light
the ordered the principled the honest
now right over here is a key symbol of
Zoroastrianism that you might see it's
called the fire of AHA I'm probably
mispronouncing it para bajar and there's
a lot of symbolism here it shows the
connection of the universe to humanity
you see the depiction of a human being
here and the three layers of the wings
depict these three very important ideas
in Zoroastrianism the first layer is is
good thoughts the second layer right
over here of the wings are good words
and then the third layer here is good
actions good actions and it makes sense
you kind of imagine this idea that good
thoughts lead to good words and that
combined they can lead to good actions
and on the tale here and these are the
things you should avoid these are the
bad thoughts the bad actions or the bad
thoughts the bad words and the bad
actions along lines this idea of dualism
especially the fascination with the
ideas of light fire is a very important
element of the Zoroastrian faith in fact
if you visit a Zoroastrian temple you
will see an eternal fire and they feed
that fire five times a day another very
important element of the faith is water
and the sacred texts for the
Zoroastrians
is called the avesta and the Avesta is
written in a language called avestan and
it's called Avastin because it's the
language that the Avesta was written in
but it's written in a religion in a
language that is closely related to
ancient Sanskrit and so there's probably
some connections or for sure there are
some connections between ancient
Hinduism and the the progenitor or some
of the pre-existing ID
is that mite that Zarathustra developed
or might have built on top of now one of
the really interesting things about
Zoroastrianism that even though today
it's a it's a relatively small faith on
the order of less than two hundred
thousand people around the world
practice it and most of them are in
India and the United States at one time
it was you could view it as the state
religion of ancient Persia but
eventually in the 7th century CE II when
/ when Persia or Iran became Islamic you
have a Zoroastrian Diaspora especially
moving to Indiana and eventually places
like the United States although there
are still practicing zoroastrians in
Iran but above and beyond the continuing
legacy of the Zoroastrians they've had a
lot of influence on some of the major
religions of the world and what you have
on this timeline here I've made some of
the major religions you see up here in
in blue you have Judaism and the reason
why I draw the dotted line is these are
periods and it's not exactly these
language these religions are evolving
and they're forming and they're getting
more and more of tradition over time so
you hear Judaism and of course
Christianity is in a lot of ways built
on top of Judaism Jesus was a was Jewish
you have Islam right over here which of
the major world religions is one of the
newest in a lot of ways built or related
to Christianity and Judaism and even
though the Zoroastrianism is related and
it kind of comes out of a similar kind
of kind of early Arian people type of
religion it has a lot of influence on
some of these other traditional or these
mainstream religions that we have in the
world today as we mentioned it's it's
viewed as a monotheistic religion and
it's also had a direct influence on for
example Christianity so right over here
this is from John Baker who's a famous
Christian theologian he wrote in his
book world religions that angels the end
of the world a final judgment the
resurrection and heaven and hell
received form and substance from
Zoroastrian beliefs in
in Christian tradition the three wise
men the three kings the Three Magi that
visit the baby Jesus Magi this is
referring to Zara streon priests who are
visiting the baby Jesus and the word
magic comes from the word Magi because
the johast the Zoroastrian elite the
priests they were very well they were
very capable in the sciences of
astronomy and they were also we're very
well known for their astrology and so
some people associated them with magical
capabilities also has close ties to
Islam the the sacred fire in
Zoroastrianism is fed five times a day
Zoroastrians or Astra UNS pray five
times a day and before prayer they go
through a ritual around washing
themselves for to cleanse themselves
where they wash themselves three times
before each prayer that is something
that we see in Islam so Zoroastrianism
it's the the faith of ancient Persia
popularized by Cyrus the Great and it's
a living religion even today although
it's a much smaller population that
practices it but as we've seen it's had
a lot of influence on many of the major
world religions